I think the most important thing
then I have learned
is it,
there's more to learn
that we should,
that we,
that we should all be hungry for a
lifetime.
I mean,
for example,
at my next birthday I'll be 68 all the
great scientific discoveries made by all
the great geniuses were largely made
when they were in their twenties and
thirties
and yet I became about two years ago,
obsessed with particle physics
and I was determined to understand it
before I died.
I could not have done that if I hadn't
learned to read when I was young,
if I hadn't had the opportunity to study
science courses in my high school.
And I lived in the second poorest state
in the United States,
which most people my age and my state
did not have.
I happened to go to a bigger high school
with people who
understood we had to get good science
and math teachers there.
And if I hadn't gone to,
in my case,
Georgetown University,
which was a jesuit university and I
hadn't been subject to the kind of
rigors that the jesuits impose,
which made me realize that however much
I thought I knew and how real smart I
was,
I didn't know very much and I wasn't
very smart.
I had a lot to deliver.
So that's the most important thing.
I learned that your brain is a gift and
we now know that people well into their
late sixties and seventies can form new
neural networks so that even though your
brain begins to shrink and your thirties
and does throughout your life stance,
none of us ever use even close to half
of our brainpower.
We got a lot left and we will in our
light on our last day on earth,
we'll have a lot left.
So the idea that we now know as a
scientific measure because of all the
brain scanning technology that we can
form these networks and that we formed
them best were most likely to form new
neural networks later in life by
learning something new.
So if I said I was interested in
particle physics and also in
astrophysics and I'm trying to figure
out what it means that we've located 20
planets outside our solar system in the
last five years,
it seemed to have enough density and be
far enough away from their sons that
they might be able to support life.
That may be the answer to the Russia
Ukraine problem and attack from out an
attack from outer space.
We'll immediately unite us.
All
members of Congress in the U s will
immediately start hugging each other and
singing Kumbaya.
But anyway,
I can form new neural networks doing
that cause I don't know anything about
it or I did and when I started,
a theoretical physicist would do better
going to Suzuki piano lessons with his
grandchild or her grandchild and just
playing if you knew nothing about music.
But this is an incredible thing that the
most important thing I learned is that
it's important to keep on learning that
you should stay hungry and that their
greatest gift can be even as your body
begins to fail.
If your mind is still working,
you need to use it
[inaudible].